♫♫ Musique ♫♫
Iznogoud ?
Mais qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Je fais du son là
Putain mais c'est excellent
On peut fait un feat ? Ah tu veux feater ?
Ouais !
Okay
Alors avec moi !
One, two, three, four
♫♫ Musique ♫♫
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent !
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
En fait, moi la vie j'comprend ap
Putain je reviens de Normandie là, jsuis totalement jetlagué
Je déteste le café
Bon à part celui du StarBucks
Ma chemise ?
En fait c'est une collab Givenchy-Lidl
J'ai la fibre chez moi ouais
Par contre c'est chelou j'ai accès qu'à Konbini, Vice et les Unrock
Et si on faisait une petite balade digestive mais en segway ?
C'est carrément badass
Excusez-moi vous avez des balisto au sègle ?
En fait moi je vis constamment entre L.A et Tokyo c'est-à-dire à Roubaix
C'est simple j'ai acheté toutes les Vans depuis leurs sorties
J'aime pas trop faire des figures en skate ouais j'préfère cruiser ouais
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Nan mais OMG
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
En fait moi la vie j'comprends ap
Parfois j'ai besoin de me déconnecter pendant au moins 10 minutes quoi
J'adore Platon il fait des putains de tweets
Ouais j'ai souscrit à une assurance anti-racket ouais et alors ?
Ouais j'suis carrément full vegan maintenant ouais
Bon à part quand y a de la très très bonne viande
Et si on se faisait une expo street art ?
Non désolé je suis pas dispo demain en soirée nan j'mixe... chez moi... tout seul
Nice
J'pense que je vais me faire un 16e tatou au niveau de la teub
Waaw
Ouais j'ai fait quelques photos avec mon appareil jetable t'auras le résultat dans deux semaines
Amazing
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Attend mais lol
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
En fait moi la vie j'comprends ap
Attend mais t'as une vie sociale ?
Ouais si tu mets un pouce en l'air c'est parce que c'est cool
si tu mets un pouce en bas c'est parce que c'est under, under, underground
Waaw
C'était clairement excellent
C'était totalement fucked up
Excuse-moi j'ai une petite question
Est-ce qu'on a pas fait un putain de tube là ?
Carrément mec c'était juste insane
Incroyable
Attend
Est-ce que finalement il est pas déjà dépassé ?
Ouais j'avoue
J'aime up
Ouais j'aime up
J'aime up c'est un peu has been
Ouais moi aussi j'aime up c'est has been de ouf
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
Putain mais c'est excellent
J'adore le concept
C'est clairement fucked up
Viens sur mon Tumblr
En fait moi la vie j'comprends ap